so the story is I have 14 siblings right
whoa whoa I didn't know that yeah you
have 14 siblings are they all from the
same the youngest nine are adopted from
all over the world wow yeah so it was a
way to I think let me like get a head
start on paying off College because
there's no way my parents were gonna pay
for 15 kids hold on hold on
I mean
it's I I hate having in my calendar
going I gotta send my brother something
oh I gotta send my uh you know I gotta
call my sister you gotta call 15 people
I mean if you were to talk to my
siblings I'm the worst 13. no 14. we're
both wrong right
I don't call it I mean I'm the worst I
the only I know my birthday and I know
my older brother's birthday because he's
one day after me the rest of that I get
updates from my sisters like really you
don't know anybody's birthday no not I
don't know you know your mom's I bet
nope you don't know your dad's nope I
mean they're gonna listen to this and
they probably they know this they know I
don't I'm the worst at that stuff I'm so
bad at that are you bad at remembering
or memorizing
um I'm no so because of acting I think
I'm really good at memorizing things for
a short period of time and then gone you
know like if you made me learn a script
I could learn that real quick but then
if you ask me three weeks from now I
wouldn't have a clue I'd be like what
yeah I understand you know like it's
just been trained in my head to like
learn things like I always did good on
tests because I would cram study for
them and then you know if there was ever
like a recap or surprise is oh I was
feeling that because I was like wait
what so you do well in school uh I did
when I was younger right so five years
old you guys all go how many do you go
to this audition I don't that's a good
question I need to actually a handful of
us a handful of you yeah and they so you
did a showcase something yeah like you
know when I was like looking for
uh
young talented you know there's a bunch
of names I can't even remember but you
know how many did they choose
uh how many did they
that's not you know what these are great
questions I if I if I start just
answering them I'm gonna be like but it
started it started you yeah yeah that's
what started it all yeah and then also
like I was definitely younger and my
older siblings were the same sort of
thing looked younger mature my parents
you know my mom ruled with an iron fist
so like you know we we listened to her
like my mom's a great mom like I we like
you would see kids on set crying or like
being disobedient running around that
was never us we would listen if my mom
said like hey you're gonna act like this
be mature don't embarrass us we did that
why did you listen to her